[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لطالما كان نظام
العقوبات هو السلاح الدبلوماسيه المفضله
لدى الولايات المتحده ضد روسيا ايران
والصين غير ان نجاعه هذه العقوبات بات
التسبيه وفقا تقرير صادر عن مجله فرنز
التي حذرت من تراجع قوه الردعي للعقوبات
الامريكيه المفروضه التي ادت الى بزوغ
ظاهره جديده بين تلك الدول تتمثل في
مقاومه العقوبات المفروضه عبر اساليب
حديثا حيث تقول فرعنا فارس انه مع اعتماد
واشنطن بشكل متزايد على العقوبات بدات
روسيا والصين وايران في دعم اقتصادها
الاقتصادي للعقوبات الامريكيه ما تسبب في
تراجع فاعليتها فقطعوا ايران عن نظام
سويفت العالمي وفرض عقوبات على روسيا
وايضا واشنطن حربا تجاريه مع الصين ساهم
في مقاومه الجزاءات العقبيه من طرف طهران
بكين
وتوضح المجله ان احدى الطرق التي ساعدت
هذه البلدان مقاومه العقوبات الامريكيه في
مقاومه هذه العقوبات اذا هي مقايضه
العملات الثنائيه ما سمح لها بتجاوز
الدولار الامريكي وتطويري انظمه دفع بديله
لنظام سويفت واعتماد العملات الرقميه التي
ساهمت هي الاخرى في الهروب من العقوبات
الامريكيه وبعد اقتصاداتهم وهنا ترى
المجله انه في افضل السيناريوهات سيعزز
تطوير الجزاءات المتعمده او المتعدده
الاطراف متعدده الاطراف انشا اطار عالميه
لتحسين فاعليهتها
[موسيقى]
هناك في الموضوع من موسكو مع تيمور دوار
الخبير في قطاع الاعمال والعلاقه الدوليه
ومن واشنطن ايهاب عباس الباحث في الشؤون
الامريكيه مرحبا بكم
الكريمين تيمور في موسكو ابدا معك هل
تعتقد وتؤيد ما ذهبت اليه لان العقوبات
الامريكيه او سياسه العقوبات الامريكيه قد
فقدت فاعليهتها
اه انا لا استطيع ان اتفق اييي بالطبع
ماهر بما ذكر
ام امتصاص الصدمه من قبل روسيا
وفعل افعال مضاده لتلك العقوبات
لامتصاص الصدمه فقط
12 ميناء روسي
المفاعل الان ثلاثه
ذهابا وايابا وكل ما يترتب على ذلك من
فوضى في اللوجستيات همم هناك عقوبات
تكنولوجيه ايضا في الصادرات والواردات
منطقه الحرب التي ينبت بها الحبوب انتم
تعلمون ما حدث اه التضخم في الازدياد ااه
اعتقد نسبه همم ناقص ال جي بي سوف يكون
اول
ناتج المحلي السنه القادمه قد يكون اربعه
بالماء
ربما اكثر في حين ان المصادر الرسميه
الروسيه تتحدث عن اثنين فقط بغض يعني خذ
في الاعتبار تدبير همم الغرب ليه خصوصيه
تيمور باقي الدول التي فرضت عليها امريكا
عقوبات هل ترى كذلك ان هذه الدول تمكنت
قليلا من
ليس من امتصاص الصدمه بل كذلك تجاوز هذه
العقوبات ربما والالتفاف عليها
الله تقصد الكتله الغربيه ليس كذلك اقصد
ايران ان كان الصين
غيرها من الدول
تشوف ااا حضرتك ااا العقوبات التي تلقتها
روسيا لم يتلقاها اي دول سابقا في التاريخ
تلك العزله الاقتصاديه ان صحه تعبير اه لم
تؤثر في روسيا كثيرا نعم سوف يترتب هناك
يتراكم عبر السنوات قادمه ااه ااه الفعل
او همم السلبي همم لكن اذا اخذنا ايران ما
همم يعني لم تفعل اي شيء الى عقبات نعم
هناك موضوع العمله همم الذين يتعاملون مع
الايرانيين يدركون ان هذه ليست بمشكله
الصين ليس بمشكله هؤلاء انطلقوا
ربما سوف يكونون الرائدين فيها في
الاقتصاد في العالم
العقوبات وانها غير المهم سيدي العقوبات
هذه ليست قانونيه وهذا مهم
طيب سعودي لك لماذا تعتبرها غير قانونيه
ولكن اخذ رايي ضيفي من واشنطن استاذ ايهاب
عباس هل فعلا سياسه العقوبات الامريكيه
فقدت فاعليتها برايك في التاثير على قرار
الدول
اهلا بحضرتك الكريم
وكل عام وانتم بخير جميعا بكل تاكيد
العقوبات الامريكيه لم تعد كما كانت قبل
ذلك السبب في هذا الامر ان الدول تعلمت
والاقتصاديات اصبحت اكثر قربا من بعضها
البعض والخطوط التجاريه اصبحت مفتوحه
والعالم اصبح قريه صغيره جدا وبالتالي اي
دوله تتعرض لعقوبات اقتصاديه تستطيع ان
تلتف عليها وتتغلب عليها بكل دوله بقدر
حجمها الاقتصادي والتجاري والسياسي
وعلاقتها الدوليه بمعنى اذا ما فرضت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عقوبات على
روسيا ليس كما تفرض هذه العقودات على ذلك
مثلا روسيا اقتصاد كبير قوي لديها قدرات
انتاجيه في عدد كبير من المجالات الحيويه
للعالم اجمع وبالتالي تستطيع ان تجد دائما
البدائل ل همم والاسواق بدلا من الولايات
المتحده والغرب مثلا وتستطيع تحمي هذه
التجاره الخارجيه لها بقدراتها العسكريه
وعلاقتها طبعا الدبلوماسيه القويه مع عدد
كبير من دول العالم بعكس مثلا فنزويلا لما
تتعرض لعقوبات امريكيه لن تكون همم بهذا
القدر من القوه كي تتصدى اقتصاديا وتجاريا
مثل هذه العقوبه وبالتالي القوه الامريكيه
في التاثير على عن طريق فرض العقوبات
نستطيع ان نقول اليوم انها اصبحت اقل
تاثيرا عندما تطبق مع الدول الكبرى لكن مع
الدول الصغرى من الممكن ان يقول لها تاثير
بالاضافه لشيء مهم جدا روسيا يعني بعد ان
بدات الحرب في اوكرانيا بشهر تقريبا او
شهرين وبدات العقوبات تزداد همم اعتقد
خرجت رئيسه البنك المركزي او شخص مسؤول
كبير هناك وقال ان روسيا كانت تستعد لمثل
هذا الامر منذ سنه على الاقل وهذا سيخفف
من الاثار السلبيه على الاقتصاد الروسي
هناك اثار سلبيه على الاقتصاد الروسي بكل
تاكيد نعم ولكن الاثار السلبيه ايضا على
الاقتصاديات الغربيه وعلى الولايات
المتحده وانا كمواطن امريكي اعيش هنا
واعلم كيف تاثرت بالباك فاير او العقوبات
الاقتصاديه العكسيه
كذلك على الدول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
طيب استاذ تيمور في موسكو رايتك تهز براسك
عندما تحدث ضيفا من واشنطن على مساله
تاثير العقوبات على روسيا وبان روسيا كان
مستعده قبل سنه من فرض هذه العقوبات يعني
الاقصى والاضخم في التاريخ ربما على على
روسيا لماذا تعترض على هذه النقطه
هو مش موضوع اعترض الموضوع كله هو ان
روسيا لا اعتقد ان هي كانت مستعده لذلك
لانها حتى اخر لحظه كانت تصدر
النقد
الاجنبي في الى الخارج وانتم تعلمون ان تم
استحواذ على
630 مليار دولار ما بينهم يورو واصول
بالدولار واليورو في الخارج فالاداره
الروسيه الحاليه الكريمه
اعتقد لم يكونوا يتوقعون مثل هذا رد الفعل
من قبل الغرب لكن ان لم يستطع روسيا
المناوره يعني همم يعني هي في المقابل
فرضت عقوبات عرفت كيف تناول الغرب ام لا
لا
يعني تلك العقوبات شوف هناك في الميزان
الضفتين
هناك عندما نتحدث عن الاقتصاد اا دعك من
الجيو استراتيجيه الموضوع كبير للغايه لا
يعني لا يختصر في ربع ساعه
هناك موضوع التنميه التنمويه روسيا
الاتحاديه بهذه العقوبات سوف ترجع الى
عقود من السنين من حيث
هذا الشيء اهم من يعني تاثيرها سيكون ربما
ليس على المدى المنظور على المدى البعيد
الابعد يعني سنرى همم تاثرا كبيرا بهذه
العقوبات ليس لحظيا يعني
التاثير التاثير كبير للغايه همم
الكريم اللي يدرك ذلك بالاضافه الى ان
هناك تاثير سياسي في السياسه الداخليه ما
هيك عن من يؤيد ومن يعرض هذه
العمليه العسكريه انصحها التعبير لكن
التداعيات اه قد لا تكون نقطه مه جدا نعم
انا احاول ان اخذ جميع زوايا الموضوع في
صحيح في ربع ساعه المساله تبدو صعبه قليلا
ولكن نعم استاذ اياد همم ما رايك نقطه
مهمه جدا وصل اليها الاستاذ تيمور في
موسكو ان العقوبات صحيح يمكن الان ااه
روسيا استطاعت ان تمتص صدمه هذه العقوبات
كان هناك محاوله للالتفاف ايجاد بدائل
تعاون مع الصين مع ايران مع دول اخرى
معاقبه ايضا من واشنطن والغرب همم ولكن
الاثر ليس لحظيا بل سنرى اثر العقوبات
الامريكيه لاحقا على المدى البعيد ما رايك
يعني بكل تاكيد اتفق طبعا يعني اي عقوبات
من شانها ان تفرض على اي دوله من الدول
بكل تاكيد سيكون لها تاثير لان
التنميه تتاثر بشكل كبير جدا الدخل القومي
يتاثر العلاقات التجاريه تتاثر بكل تاكيد
ولكن في المقابل ايضا هذا لا يعني ان
الولايات المتحده والغرب لم يتاثر يعني
انا اتحدث هنا من واشنطن اتحدث من قلب
صانع هذا القرار القرار العقوبات واا
اشاهد تحديدا ما الذي يحدث للاقتصاد
الامريكي اليوم الاقتصاد الامريكي يعاني
بشكل كبير البطاله مرتفعه المواطن
الامريكي اصبح يعمل في وظيفه واثنتين
وثلاث حتى يستطيع ان يقوم بدفع فواتيره
وتكلفه الحياه وبالتالي همم يعني همم كان
مثال بسيط جدا مره اخرى جالون البنزين من
اثنين دولار ونصف الى 65$ فهذا تضخم رهيب
جدا كذلك في بقيه السلع المهمه والحيويه
للمواطنين الامريكيين هل ستاثر اكثر من
الاقتصاد الروسي لا اقول انه اكثر
الاقتصاد الروسي ولكن على الاقل تقديس
يتاثر لوضع كبير جدا ودكتور دويدار يعلم
ان البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي حاول التغلب
على التضخم اا مرات عديده برفع اسعار
الفائده الفائده ولم يستطع حتى الان اذن
الاقتصاد الامريكي يتاثر
يعني استاذ دويدار كذلك في موسكو
[موسيقى]
لهذه العقوبات سلاح ذو حدين كما يقول ضيف
حتى المعسكر الغربي تاثر همم بها وان كان
بشكل اقل همم في ختام هذا الموضوع طيب اذا
كانت مساله العقوبات انت وصفتها قبل قليل
العقوبات غير قانونيه من قبل امريكا اذا
لم تكن همم بهذا المفعول السحري بهذا
التاثير الكبير جدا التي ترضع بها مني هذا
نقول او المعارضين للسياساتها همم هل ترى
ان الولايات المتحده يعني تفقد قوتها ام
لا هي تبحث ربما عن اليات اخرى همم يمكن
ان تكون اكثر تاثيرا في المستقبل من
العقوبات
الولايات المتحده
وطوال البال
واقتصاد رقم واحد في العالم
ما يفعلونه
للاسف الشديد اتمنى ان يكون مدركين
انه ما يفعلونه ضد
القوه الثانيه ليس من حيث المرتبه انما
موازي الولايات المتحده من قبل ثلاثه
النووي انه عمل قد يؤدي الى فناء هناك
لكن ما يفعلونه هم متاكدين منهم نحن نتضرر
وانا اقرر بذلك في حين انه هناك ثغرات
طبعا في السوق لايك لان هيك يعني ثلاث
شركه غربيه منها منتجه اغلقت في روسيا في
يعني واحد وسببت اه بطاله وهناك ثغرات
كثيره الان همم
من تركيا الصين والشرق الاوسط من الشركات
المنتجه العربيه
التركيه يدخلون السوق الان همم
يتم نوعا ما
تغيير لكن ما هو بعيد تماما عن ما كنا
عليه من علاقات ماليه بالغرب واقتصاديه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لكما ضيفي من موسكو تيمور
دوار الخبير في قطاع الاعمال والعلاقات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن ايهاب عباس الباحث في
الشئون الامريكيه